new year's day is in three weeks and
we're gonna help you ring in the new
year right here on channel eight once
again
kirsten and brian they're going to be
covering celebrations from across the
country from new york's times square
to our own las vegas strip eight news
now will be live from
stadium swim at the new circuit resort
downtown with performances from zoe
bowie
the eli young band and strip headliners
like tape face
now we want you to have a safe new year
so we're going to be social distancing
we're going to do covid screenings and
testing
follow all the rules and make sure we
give you a safe product on television
it's been a challenging year for a lot
of us so
during the show on new year's eve we're
going to be raising money for food banks
all across the country with this super
bowl of caring
our goal is to hit 1 million meals any
money donated here though it's gonna
stay right here in las vegas
and we hope you have a safe home new
year's eve
uh celebration join us the show starts
at 9 runs through 12 35
and we hope you'll tune in